Taylor Swift's sexy date night look et  has the exclusive pics 26 year old  stepped out in this lucky look on  Tuesday for a dinner date with Calvin  Harris in Los Angeles  Taylor paired her little black dress  with a star adorned headband metallic  open-toed heels and went with bright red  lips and I witnessed LZ te that the  couple enjoyed dinner in the back room  at Giorgio Baldi adding quote it was  just the two of them having a romantic  evening out they were there for almost  two hours  Taylor was in high spirits with her man  the source says quote she was playful  and happy to do some left the restaurant  around 10:30 Calvin drove and bodyguards  followed 2016 is shaping up to be a big  year for the duo sources confirmed to ET  that they also spent the holidays  together